the FBI visited me because of something
I did on the internet and this is that
story when I was 14 my school gave me
these new planners which was super tight
because you know I was in Compton you
don't get much new anything couldn't
wait to just plan anything like if
somebody was like yo I'm beating you up
after school I was like all right what's
your valence cuz I need a planning I
looked in there and they had a homework
help site and I was like all right let
me go to this site Lee I'm so hype all
the homework help site I'm supposed to
be other students helping each other but
who's doing that the first threat that
kind of catches my eye is the find your
internet girlfriend and boyfriend thread
so I went in there because you only
needed three things to find your
internet girlfriend a boyfriend a SL
baby that's age sex and locations for
all the younger people who never had to
experience linking up with people on the
net and AOL chat rooms and stuff found a
match
we're hitting it off strong and we're
very mature for age we skipped all the
like internet first date stuff we went
straight to internet sex we're going at
it and it becomes a daily routine for me
you go to school come home cyber sex and
every night it's a great routine and it
was cool because I was like the John
Steinbeck of cyber sex I was just real
nice with the pen and my dad he worked
at the apartment complex so he had his
own office in the complex that I can
sneak off to and had a deadbolt lock so
nobody can get in there and my dad
thought I was being studious he was like
dang all of a sudden my son he wants to
go in here and get his homework done man
I should have got him a planner years
ago finally I did the math in my head it
was like whoa
actually that show on HBO real sex
taught me I could jack off to this so
then I get back there I log on ready to
go she does not log on
she doesn't log on the next day and the
next I'm confused I'm hurt for a bit but
then I go on with my life because life
moves fast when you're 14 one day I'm
chilling at home and there's a knock at
the door there's a white man in a suit
with a briefcase
I live in Compton California and if a
white man in a suit briefcase shows up
at your door in Compton California
nothing good could come from it close
that door I didn't have the wisdom that
I have now
so I say hello and he goes excuse me are
you
if the Waddy way and I was like yeah and
he was like oh thank god okay this is
gotten weird immediately but I go and
get my parents and since there's a man
in a suit here we get to sit in the
Velvet Room y'all know the velvet room
that special room your parent has for
some reason no kids can hang out in my
parents are like what is going on and
I'm just like oh okay
till he opens his mouth and he says hey
I'm here with the FBI I was like what
wait he's like yeah so apparently your
son has been using language online
that's pretty advanced for his age like
I said I was the John Steinbeck of
cybersex he had to come and make sure
that I wasn't an adult talking to a kid
online and having cybersex this is bad
mostly bad because this is the second
weird sex thing that my parents would
hit up about because the first weird sex
thing was in fourth grade I got into
drawing boobs because I figured out that
if you draw W's and then put dots in
them it turned into moves I was blown
away if I got a new book from school
boobs if I got some more boobs and then
I got sloppy and turned in the homework
with the boobs on it and then my teacher
had to go and be all extra and called my
parents I was like you want to know what
your son's doing here
remember that briefcase I was talking
about well he opens it up and pulls out
a nice thick stack of paper and starts
handing it to my parent tonight I
immediately started panicking I was a
romantic so when I would get into the
cyber sex mode I wouldn't just jump in
there I would set the theme on yahoo
instant messenger to rain hearts down
and they printed that out to all four of
us are sitting in this room in silence
as they flip through the pages like they
finally closed the pieces of paper look
up at the agent it was like all right
sir it's fine we'll handle this and they
walk him out and they close the door
time stopped business is gonna be a
closed casket or open casket funeral and
they turn around and they just start
laughing
and you know that was honestly worse
than any other punishment because what I
did on those pages what I did with that
pin was art so for it to be laughed at
for the next few years my nickname was
chocolate syrup because that was one of
my lines in there see I said I'd drizzle
you in chocolate syrup which as a
14-year old seems like a good idea but
now I'm gonna don't and understand that
requires too much setup and clean up so
I guess be careful what you do on the
internet because you never know who's
watching
[Music]